das virus ist noch lange nicht besiegt
dazu braucht es einen impfstoff der vier
millionen ja milliarden menschen reicht
mehr als den äußerst vorsichtigen
einstieg in den ausstieg wollte die
politik deshalb heute nicht riskieren
sie gibt dem gesundheitsschutz weiter
voran
trotz des hohen wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen preises das ist richtig so
bislang ist deutschland dank unserer
disziplin gut durch die krise gekommen
keine italienischen verhältnisse keine
bilder wie aus new york eine ganz große
koalition aus bundesregierung und allen
ministerpräsidenten samt grünen linken
und freidemokraten hat unser land bisher
politisch vor dem corona kollaps bewahrt
mit einer weitgehend rationalen politik
die sich von der wissenschaft beraten
lässt und überparteilich verantwortung
übernimmt was für ein unterschied zum
beispiel zu trumps vereinigten staaten
nach schulschließungen und kontaktverbot
beginnt jetzt corona phase 3 mit neuen
unübersichtlichkeit und regionalen
unterschieden und vermeidbar folgt
daraus streit über das was der nachbar
darf und ich nicht haben wir keine angst
davor
genau das macht demokratie aus corona
darf das freiheitliche nervensystem
unserer republik nicht schädigen
dabei war nicht alles gut auch bei uns
gibt es zu wenig masken und
schutzanzügen intensivbetten und tests
belastbare statistische daten über die
verbreitung des virus an den heutigen
entscheidungen ist nicht überzeugend
warum autohäuser öffnen dürfen
öffentliche gottesdienste aber verboten
bleiben
das wort europa nahm die bundeskanzlerin
auch heute wieder nicht in den mund der
berliner horizont scheint nur bis zu
unseren grenzen zu reichen
dabei gehört die eu zur lösung sie hat
uns deutschen nach dem krieg würde
zurückgegeben und nach 1989 zum großen
gewinner gemacht wir müssen dem virus
standhalten es darf auch europa nicht
besiegen